all right shireen you participated in
one of the
weekly or so conference calls that the
nfl
conducts regarding the covenant 19
situation
what did they have to say about the
outbreak that kind of quietly happened
this week for the carolina panthers
yeah eight players went on the covet 19
list and alan seals the nfl's chief
medical officer
did say it was a gathering outside of
the team facility and that's how it
spread
they were on their bye week players
gathered which they've been told not to
do
i think we can expect fines to come from
this mic we've seen it with other teams
before
but these players did gather outside the
team facility and it spread through
these players and
here we are yet with another outbreak
but this one unlike
tennessee and baltimore did not happen
within the team facility as they were on
their bye week
you know the nfl reserves the right to
impose these punishments we've seen the
punishments imposed one thing that we
haven't heard about
officially what happens with these
punishments on appeal
i've heard that more than a few of these
punishments have been
either overturned or abandoned on appeal
it's about the message that you send in
imposing the punishment and not as much
about whether or not
at the end of the day someone has to
give up a significant amount of money
but in this case it's been reiterated
multiple times now no gatherings away
from the facility
the the players are prohibited from
doing that the union has presumably
agreed to it it'll be interesting to see
what the league does
about this because as teams fade from
contention the biggest fear
for the league is that players won't be
as vigilant that they'll end up
getting exposed they'll end up having an
outbreak and will end up losing games
down the stretch maybe between
a team that is trying to play to win
to get to the playoffs or enhance
playoff positioning and a team that
just doesn't care well you should care
because as kyle rudolph told us
weeks ago you're going to lose your game
checks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports